bonsoir à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
pour ce nouveau webinaire ce soir nous
allons aborder la régression logistique
tout d'abord juste quelques informations
sur sept sur sept séances donc la
régression logistique et plus
spécifiquement la régression logistique
binaire permet de réaliser un modèle
multivariée pour comparer les effets
toutes choses égales par ailleurs de
différentes variables sur un out comme
de type binaire c'est-à-dire and outcome
que l'on peut qu des sous la forme oui
non plus spécifiquement ce soir nous
allons utiliser les données de l'enquète
histoires de vie 2003 que nous avons
déjà abordé dans des sessions
précédentes et nous allons nous
intéresser aux facteurs influençant la
pratique du sport
autrement dit nous on regarde une
variable qui est pratique un sport oui
ou non et donc on parle de bahia binaire
car on peut aussi la cote est sous la
forme 0 1 et donc avec la régression
logistique nous allons nous intéresser à
la probabilité de faire du sport nous
allons commencer déjà par ouvrir notre
r studio
donc
par ouvrir leur studio vous avez ici r
studio sous les yeux
et puis pour la séance de ce soir j'ai
déjà commencé à préparer en créant un
nouveau projet nous avions un berger la
notion de projet 1 précédemment dans un
studio donc quand je voulais comme je
voulais dit il est important de bien
séparer ces différentes analyses ont en
tout cas ces différents projets de
recherche on peut avoir plusieurs
analyses sur un même jeu de données donc
là les projets en dans les studios ils
sont visibles en haut à droite et pour
les créer c'est le bouton new project et
vous définissez un nouveau répertoire de
projets répertoire qui va contenir tous
les éléments dont on aura besoin
et puis du coup je vais faire à un
script terre et donc ce soir on va
essayer de reprendre la régression
logistique mais on va repartir du début
et c'est de faire un script au propre
qui va nous permettre de faire tout
d'abord une description univariée des
différentes variables qui nous intéresse
pour l'analyse puis une description by
varié avec un test de comparaison des
proportions et enfin la régression
logistique comme toujours très unanime
multivariée elle arrive toujours après
une première étape d' analyse
descriptive
c'est essentiel par ailleurs et ce que
nous on va pas faire car on va prendre
l'exemple
normalement avant de démarrer votre
analyse vous avez commencé par faire une
revue de la littérature pour connaître
les différents éléments qui sont pour
savoir ce que l'on en pense et surtout
les facteurs que l'on va explorer dans
l'analyse ne sortent pas nulle part on
va pas prendre toutes les variables qui
sont disponibles dans notre jeu de
données mais on a plutôt fait en amont
une revue de littérature pour avoir un
cadre théorique qui va nous permettre de
poser des hypothèses d'abord ni sur le
type de variables qui peuvent influencer
notre évènement d'intérêt alors nous
allons donc démarré par la première
étape celle qui prend en général le plus
de temps qui est celle de la préparation
des données comme toujours dans toute
analyse la préparation des données est
une étape essentielle
je vais commencer mon script je lui
donnais un titre
en général dont classe et analyse de la
pratique du sport
je vous rappelle que tous les
commentaires dans l air et dans un
script r comment simplement par le
symbole diez est que ce qui commence par
un symbole diaz ne sera donc pas
interprété comme une commande par
ailleurs petites astuces dans un studio
si vous faites suivre un commentaire qui
commence par un ou plusieurs diez
équivoque à la fin vous rajouter 4 trait
d'union
il est repéré comme étant un titre et
donc vous avez à disposition ici un
petit plan de votre document donc
première étape chargement des données
étaient package toujours petites astuces
ici j'ai mis deux diez au début de mon
commentaire ça permet de dire et j'ai
fait suivre à la fin de 4,6 rsa permet
de dire hélas audio ce site un titre de
niveau 2 et vous allez voir ici qu'il va
y avoir une structuration des titres et
on va pouvoir aussi par cette entrée l'a
commencé à naviguer dans le script
première chose que je vous invite à
faire toujours au début d'un script
c'est de charger toutes les toutes les
package dont toutes les extensions dont
vous aurez besoin et aux besoins au fur
et à mesure que l'on va lancer notre
analyse on va pouvoir compléter cette
liste donc on va démarrer avec le taille
diverse qui va être bien utile label d'
nous l'avons vu ça va nous permettre de
définir des étiquettes sur des variables
et puis je veux aussi chargé l'extension
questionnaire d'une part parce qu'elle
fournit des petites fonction bien utile
au quotidien comme des scripts qu'on a
vu comme un frère mais également puisque
donc pour ce soir on va utiliser les
données de
de l'enquète histoires de vie 2003 qui
est fournie par kwh actionnaires et que
je vais charger avec data hdv 2003 par
ailleurs on va sortir un certain nombre
de tableaux on l'a vu une extension fort
bien pratique pour faire des tableaux
très propre et très rapidement cégétiste
mairie donc je vais charger aussi jti se
marie en mémoire et tout de suite dès le
début de mon document je vais définir un
certain nombre d'options en particulier
je vais dire que je vais dire tout
simplement que je veux des tableaux
qu'ils soient rendus en français donc
m jti se marient language j'indique fr
pour le français ça va me permettre un
que tant que faire se peut j-10 m'arrive
à franciser les différents éléments des
tableaux alors c'est plus ou moins
correct mais ça c'est un premier élément
de base par ailleurs en france est la
marque des décimales c'est la virgule et
non le point et le symbole qui permet de
séparer les milliers ont peu personnel
explique marc c'est l'espace alors qu en
anglais la virgule est utilisé pour
séparer les milliers et que le point est
séparé est utilisé pour séparer la
décimale de la partie entière je vais
sauvegarder avec contrôlé sous le petit
bouton sauvegarde tout de suite mon
script dont classe et analyse pratique
sport
et c'est un fichier avec une extension
point grands airs puisque c'est un
script de code r et là je me rends
compte que j'ai fait une petite faute 1
j'écris parti que alors il m'est
possible de modifier directement le nom
du fichier en sélectionnant d'horaires
studio puis en cliquant sur win m
alors bien sûr analyse pratique sport et
un petit souci sur le zoom mais je viens
de modifier du coup le nom du fichier
ici et r studio a automatiquement fermés
ou vers le fichier en question
maintenant que nous avons nos données en
mémoire nous allons en profiter pour les
labellisés alors regardons rapidement
pour ce pour se remettre en mémoire
qu'est ce que contient hdv 2003 je vais
faire tout simplement un look fort de
hdv 2003 pour avoir une idée de comment
mais variables sont codés dans le
fichier et si je dispose des tic est ce
qu'on peut voir c'est qu'il n'ya pas
d'étiquette de variables aucune variable
d'un d'étiquettes de variables et les
variables catégorielles sont codées sous
forme de facteurs que je vois avec ici
coltime fct ce soir nous allons nous
intéresser à la pratique du sport on
dispose dans le fichier de données une
variable sport avec deux modalités non
et oui
et mme harvey littérature m'amène à
penser que la pratique du sport peuvent
varier en fonction de l'âge de
l'individu
nous avons ici un âge disponible sous
codé sous forme d' entier pour les
démographes ça signifie qu'on a un âge
révolu où ajo dernier anniversaire
petite précision normalement lorsqu'on
fait un travail sur des âges et
notamment avec d âge révolu
si on veut faire un calcul die d'âge
moyen il faudrait rajouter théoriquement
0.5 puisque les personnes qui ont entre
20 et 21 ans exactement ont en moyenne
et donc qu'ils ont 20 ans révolus
eh ben ils ont en moyenne 20 ans et demi
puisque certaines viennent de fêter
leurs 20 ans d'autres les fenêtres sont
sur le point de fêter leurs 21 ans
donc nous allons intéressé à l'âge au
sexe au niveau d'études
nous avons également à nous avons
également vu de notre littérature que la
religion en tout cas le sentiment
religion pourrait avoir potentiellement
ils nous ont une hypothèse que la
religion pour impacter la pratique du
sport
nous allons donc également prendre en
compte la variable religion qui a qui
nous dit si la personne était et
pratiquants réguliers pratiquants
occasionnels à une appartenance
religieuse sans pratiquer l'ani croyance
ni appartenance rejette la religion ou
bien ne sait pas ou ne veut pas répondre
enfin la dernière variable que nous
allons considérer ce soir pour l'exemple
c'est la variable heures tv qui nous
donne le nombre moyen d'heures passées
devant télévision par jour
encore une fois les variables
que je retiens ce soir ce sont des
variables qui sont pour l'exemple de
l'analyse mais dans les faits il
faudrait faire une revue de littérature
beaucoup plus poussé pour savoir quelles
seraient les bonnes d'hypothèses à poser
est bien identifié les variables inclus
dans l'analyse
une autre manière de voir aussi comment
sont mes données c'est de faire un view
sur hdv 2003 qui vous permet on l'est
déjà vu devoir nous donner à de manière
plus classique sous la forme d'un
tableur vous pouvez noter que l'anc est
en question possède des poids de
pondération ce soir nous n'allons pas
voir la situation particulière des
enquêtes avec les pros de pondération on
l'abordera dans une future session donc
pour ce soir nous faisons l'hypothèse
que nous avons une enquête avec l'année
championnat aléatoire simple où chaque
individu ne compte que pourra ceci posé
je vais comme on l'a vu à nos données à
ne possède pas d'étiquette de variables
je vais tout de suite définir les
étiquettes de variables on verra dans
quelle mesure ça va nous faciliter la
vie derrière mais comment on va faire
des tableaux avec guy thys mari et comme
on l'a eu comme on l'a dit précédemment
hajiti se marient prend en compte les
étiquettes de variable lorsque les
zigzags et elles existent pour avoir des
rendu un petit peu plus propre je vais
tout de suite mettre des étiquettes de
variables alors
pour cela on peut utiliser la fonction
cette variable à belz du package label
et donc je vais prendre
hdv 2003 c'est donc égale à hdv 2003 je
veux et je lui applique cette variable
label ce donc cette variable label c'est
la fonction du package la belge qui
permet avec une syntaxe à la deep la
fière de définir des étiquettes de
variables et je vais le faire que pour
les variables qui m'intéresse donc la
variable sport la variable âge
la variable sexe on a vu qu'on allait
aussi prendre en compte le niveau
d'études et le niveau d'études c'est la
variable nive études
[Musique]
la variable religieux qui est donc le
rapport à la religion et enfin la
variable heures tv qui est donc le
nombre d'heures quotidiennes de
télévision j'ai préparé mon code comme à
chaque fois qu'on développe notre script
au fur et à mesure on va exécuter le
code pour dans la console pour rappel
pour exécuter du code dans la console je
peux soit sélectionné mon code
cliquez sur run ou me met juste sur une
ligne et cliquez sur run là ça va
prendre la commande en cours et en
europe et air va tout seul détecter un
que les commandes ne sont pas fini car
il ya des virgules ou des départs en fin
de ligne et l'exécuter à la console le
raccourci pour faire ça à la main ces
contrôles enter voyez si je laisse ma
souris sur le petit bouton home run
alors vous avez une quelque chose qui
sauve la fenêtre est tout petit je suis
désolé donc vous voyez pas ce qui est
écrit mais c'est écrit en sélection et
entre parenthèses vous avez control
place hunter donc on vous rappelle le
raccourci clavier pour faire cela donc
retourné 1
si je me mets quelque part je tape
contre le leinster j'exécute la commande
en cours et je me positionne sur la nuit
suivante
l'avantagé qu'on peut du coup enchaîné
si je me mets au début de mon script
contrôle enter exact la première
commande contrôle enter la seconde et
ainsi de suite et je peux du coup lancé
mes commandes les unes après les autres
si à un moment donné vous avez des bugs
et vous ne savez pas où vous en êtes
vous pouvez toujours re démarrer votre
session aer supprimée
tout ce que vous avez en mémoire
exécuter le code du début
pour vous remettre dans l'état à ce
moment là je vais juste faire un petit
look fort dans la console pour vérifier
que ma labellisation s'est bien passé
donc look fort de hdv 2003 agrandissant
la console on voit que sport et rtv ont
bien été labellisé de même que relie
genève études âge et sexe
maintenant que mes données sont préparés
nous allons nous en nous lancer dans une
analyse descriptive univariée pour cela
je vais faire un tri à plat de
l'ensemble de mes variable d'intérêt
nous l'avons abordée dans la session sur
les statistiques descriptives nous
pouvons faire très simplement un tri à
plat avec la fonction tibial samarie
pour cela je pars de hdv 2003 je vais
sélectionner les variables qui
m'intéresse donc on leva qui m'intéresse
c'est sport âge sexe ni l'étude re-ly ge
et leur tv
et je vais passer tout cela atb
al-shammari le tableau s'affiche en bas
à droite dans le viewer
donc je vois que j'ai deux mille
individus parmi ces derniers ils sont
36% pratiquer un sport 64% ne pas
pratiquer de sport
ils ont un âge médian de 48 alors par
défaut
l'âge qui est présenté pour les
variables continue c'est la médiane et
les écarts et les caractères quartile on
à la répartition par sexe 45% 55%
le niveau d'études et on nous indique
qu'il y à 112 manquant pour ce niveau
d'études
le rapport à la religion et le nombre
médian d'heures quotidiennes passées
devant la télévision
on peut tout à fait rester sur la
médiane ou alternativement une
possibilité est plutôt de regarder du
côté de la moyenne
il m'est possible quand j'appelle thi
binh son mari de préciser que pour les
variables continue je veux voir une
moyenne mais a il met aussi possible de
passer la fonction et je vais mettre au
début mon script thème jti se marie
mines sd
quand on applique ce thème est bien
dorénavant à chaque fois qu'on fera un
tableau avec tbilissi marie par défaut
sauf si on spécifie autre chose le
tableau présentera plutôt les moyennes
et les écarts tic
si j'aurais exécute le tableau je
dispose du coup maintenant d'un âge
moyen 48 ans et d'un nombre moyen
d'heures passées devant la télévision de
2,25 et on voit qu'ils me mente 5
observation pour les heures quotidiennes
passées devant la télévision
alors un autre élément qui peut être un
petit peu perturbant c'est que les
pourcentages alors tibial se marie à une
fâcheuse tendance à présenter
les pourcentages et les arrondir en pour
avoir deux chiffres significatifs
ça veut dire que là un pourcentage comme
11 % 18 % n'a pas de chiffres après la
virgule
alors que 1 9 7% et présentez là cette
fois ci avec un chiffres après la
virgule
si je souhaite uniformiser cela à tibi
elle se marie je peux personnaliser le
paramètre dj's et je vais le changer
uniquement pour les variables
catégorielles et je vais dire for all
catégorie col tilde et je vais passer un
1 0 et 1
alors petite précision c'est vrai que la
syntaxe de tiberi elle peut être un
petit peu perturbante au début la
plupart des paramètres prennent quelque
chose qui se crée sous la forme
sélection de variables c'est le nom
d'une variable ou une fonction telle que
hall catégorie col qui permet de
sélectionner toutes les variables
catégorielles tilde valeur du paramètre
on peut aussi si on veut modifier les
paramètres pour plusieurs types de
variables avoir recours du coup à une
liste avec à chaque fois non variable ou
ses lecteurs de variables tilde valeur
du paramètre notre élément c'est que si
vous regardez pour les variables
catégorielles on présente ici deux
statistiques on présente les effectifs
899 et les pourcentages
du coup il me faut donner deux valeurs
d'arrondi aucuns chiffres après la
virgule pour les effectifs un chiffres
après la virgule pour le pourcentage si
je refais mon tableau j'obtiens ceci
donc avec un chiffre après la virgule
pour les pourcentages
par défaut on nous présente les
effectifs suivis des pourcentages
là encore une fois il peut y avoir des
variations suivre les disciplines jeu
suivant les écoles suivront les
universités dans certains cas on
préférait plutôt présenté le pourcentage
est entre parenthèses ou entre crochets
les effectifs il est possible de
modifier cela avec le paramètre
statistiques
donc là je vais modifier c'est ici que
pour les données catégorielles et je
vais indiquer ce que je veux et j'ai
donné une chaîne de texte pour cela moi
ce que je veux c'est présenté les
pourcentages puis entre crochets
les effectifs alors la syntaxe est un
petit peu particulière on va regarder
l'aide de thé bio se marie pour mieux
comprendre dans satistiques on peut
choisir et ça nous est résumé dans la
partie statistiques argumente on peut
choisir différentes valeurs pour les
variables catégorielles on peut choisir
n pour fréquent pour le pour le pour la
poule pour les effectifs grands thèmes
qu'elle dénominateur petit pays qu'est
le pourcentage mis en forme et pour les
variables continue on peut avoir la
médiane la moyenne sd minimum p au p 25
pour le 25ème personnes tel ou p 0,3
pour le troisième personne
l'idée c'est que c'est à chaque fois
inscrit entre accolades et c'est pour
dire on va remplacer cet indicateur
entre accolade par la valeur et tout le
reste c'est la manière de mettre en
forme
donc là je dis je veux le pourcentage
suivi d'un espace d'un crochet de
l'effectif est l'accroché ferment et
pour ceux que ça intéresse c'est un type
de syntaxe qui correspond à la fonction
hulu et la fonction glu elle permet de
faire assez facilement des
transformations sur des textes
[Musique]
alors cette fois ci j'ai bien mais
pourcentage suivi des effectifs sauf que
il faut que inverse mais arrondi
donc c'est un chiffres après la virgule
pour le pourcentage 0 pour l'effectif
et j'obtiens le tableau attendu ils
m'ont juste le symbole pour son je vais
donc leur ajouter ici donc j'ai
maintenant ma présentation avec mes
pourcentage mais effectif entre crochets
et ici moyenne écart-type tibial samarie
vous ramène toujours en bas comment les
choses sont présentées dont pourcentage
effectifs et moyennes et karting
maintenant investiguons un petit peu
plus ce tableau l'âge ici est simplement
codé en temps variable continue et ce
qui va poser potentiellement problème à
l'analyse un pardon et je vois qu'il ya
quelques questions avant alors quelques
remarques sur l'écran illisible
n'oubliez pas on est sur un lavis
youtube etc abandonné suivant la qualité
de connexion internet vous allez avoir
un flux en haute définition aux
mauvaises et finition qui vous est
envoyé pour le coup ce qui envoya
youtube c'est du 1080p
si vraiment l'écran est invisible
pendant un live n'hésitez pas à regarder
la vidéo a posteriori alors à quoi
correspond le 17
entre parenthèses au niveau de l'âge si
je regarde dans le pied de page
ça correspond à la moyenne est à l'écart
type donc par défaut tibi elle se marie
pour une variable continu présente la
médiane est entre parenthèses
l'intervalle interquartile c'est-à-dire
l'intervalle entre le premier kart il
est le troisième quart tine
si l'on applique au tout début thème
jean marie mines sd par défaut pour les
variables qui continue sera présentée la
moyenne suivi de l'écart type
ce que vous voyez c'est que là encore
les moyennes écart type sont présentés
avec un nombre de chiffres qui qui
dépendent et on peut forcer donc
automatiquement en fait il a juste
suivre la situation et on peut aussi
ajuster le nombre de décimales
de la même manière qu'on l'a fait pour
les variables 4 catégorielles ici et
puis si vous le voulez avec statistiques
vous pouvez choisir quoi afficher pour
les variables continue donc dans ce cas
vous feriez statistics égal au continuo
et vous diriez ce que vous voulez
afficher parmi la médiane la moyenne
l'écart type la variance le minimum le
maximum les ports sont les personnes
t-il voire même passer votre propre
fonction pour des choses plus avancé les
pourcentages tibial scénarii sont ils
établissent sans les valeurs manquantes
sinon comment obtenir les pourcentages
excluant les valeurs manquantes
alors les pourcentages qui sont affichés
sont sans les valeurs manquantes
si vous regardez par exemple la variable
enseignement niveau d'études
j'ai deux mille personnes et sur cd ni
personne l'information est manquante
pour le 112 individu pour ses cent douze
individus on nous dit juste que
l'information est manquante et ensuite
sur les autres individus nous avons les
effectifs et le pourcentage calculé sur
des individus pour lequel la valeur
n'est pas encore le tri à plat peut-il
être fait avec toutes les variables
oui vous pouvez faire directement hdv
tibi elles se marient donc si je fais
pas de sélection en amont des variables
je veux obtenir un tableau pour tout les
valable de mon tableau hdv 2003 n'a que
vingt variable donc ça peut se faire
assez facilement
si vous avez un tableau de données qui
va commencer à voir 50 60 cents 200
variable le problème c est le temps de
calcul
comment peut-on enregistré la base de
données à genève et 2003 sous excel pour
mieux la comprendre
alors vous pouvez exporter un tableau
d'alors pour exporter un fichier au
format excel on va ouvrir page web si
vous allez sur le site analyseur et que
vous allez dans export de données vous y
trouverez les différentes fonctions pour
exporter dans différents formats et
notamment à vous pouvez utiliser la
fonction wright point xlsx de
l'extension open xlsx qui permet de
prendre un tableau de données et de
l'exporter au format excel
ceci étant dit je ne vous le recommande
pas si vous avez besoin de voir vos
données pour mieux les visualiser
passé par le viewer 2 r studio vous avez
à côté du nom ici une petite icône pour
l'activer directement ou bien on pouvait
taper la commande view avec un b
majuscule
hdv 2003 vous aurez du coup une le moyen
de visualiser vos données comme vous le
feriez sous excel
je sais que de ne pas voir les données
en direct dans les studios ça perturbe
parfois certain nombre de personnes qui
sont habitués à les voir en permanence
aux espèces est sourd sata mais le fait
que vous ne puissiez pas directement les
modifier à la main en cliquant dedans
mais que vous deviez écrire du code est
vraiment une bonne pratique parce que du
coup ça vous amène
à écrire un script de bout en bout ce
qui permet la reproductibilité de
l'analyse alors ceux qui étaient là la
semaine dernière se souviennent on avait
fait du rpt codage deux variables et on
va maintenant du coup au pouvoir le
mettre en oeuvre
on va reprendre les différentes
variables d'intérêt que je souhaite
mettre dans mon analyse pour ça je vais
exécuter mon tableau et on va regarder
si on veut garder les variables telles
quelles ou si on va les prendre de
manière différente
premièrement ma variable d'intérêt
variables explicatives c'est pratique du
sport pour faire une analyse puisqu'à
terme on va faire une régression
logistique binaire il nous faut donc
bien une variable à seulement deux
modalités
c'est le cas et il faut retenir cette
notion de modalités de référence quand
on fait une régression logistique
binaire la première modalités considéré
comme référence et la deuxième comme
l'événement a eu lieu
autrement dit comme la première
modalités c'est non ma modalités qui
s'est donc non la référence oui et la
modalité qui correspond à l'événement où
l'intérêt a eu lieu est donc en ayant
codé de cette manière là ce que l'on va
analyser c'est la probabilité de faire
du sport sinon eh oui avait été inversé
on serait en train d'analyser la
probabilité de ne pas faire du sport les
deux analyses sont complètement
symétrique
les deux peuvent se valoir n'y a pas à
dire qu'il faut l'une plutôt que l'autre
ce qui change ça change rien du point de
vue statistique
ce que ça change c'est la manière dont
vous raconter l'histoire et donc vous
allez présenter vos résultats
en effet c'est pas la même chose de se
poser du point de vue sociologique
s'intéressait à qu'est ce qui fait que
l'on fait du sport est un petit peu
différent que de se dire pourquoi on ne
fait pas de sport c'est juste l'inversé
la question mais dans la manière dont on
raconte les choses c'est pas tout à fait
pareil ici on s'intéresse donc au fait
de pratiquer un sport
deuxième variable d'intérêt la variable
âge
petit souci alors la variable âge si je
la garde tel quel elle est pour le
moment
rentré comme une variable continue et si
je n'avais tel quel dans le modèle je
ferai donc l'hypothèse à la toute fin
que il ya un effet continue de l'âge
plus on vieillit plus la pratique du
sport augmente ou diminue et on parle
alors défait linéaire les économistes
eux parfois pour tenir compte du fait
que dans un centre de car vous pouvez
avoir quelque chose qui augmente avec
l'âge puis qui diminue passé un certain
âge au qui au contraire diminue puis
augmente mettre dans les modèles l'âge
et l'âge au carré c'est une pratique
fréquente en économie dans deux
disciplines et qui permet de rendre
compte de cela en sociologie ou mon
démographie je dirais qu'il est souvent
plus intéressantes s'intéresser à des
catégories d'âge ou à des classes d'âge
ça permet quand on prend une variable
continu et qu'on la passe d'une variable
catégorielles on peut voir du coup des
effets qui varie suivant les moments de
la vie
quelque chose qui augmenterait puis
baisserait pire et augmenterait dans
lequel l'analyse je vous propose donc de
voir comment est ce que l'on fait pour
avoir plutôt des classes d'âge ce qui
nous permet de réviser la partie reco
d'âge et on a vu que cela pouvait se
faire très facilement avec les add in de
questionnaires dont je me mets ici dans
mon code à l'endroit où je veux insérer
le futur code de reco d'âge en haut je
repère le menu à dean je clique sur add
in si comme moi vous avez beaucoup de
paquets j'ai donc beaucoup d'à dean je
peux éventuellement recherché par un nom
en tapant qu'ie9 et apparaître
questionnaire ce qui m'intéresse c'est
le hadid numérique
rudge dividing
pour le coup ce qui m'intéresse donc je
vais choisir la variable arrco des c'est
dans hdv 2003 la variable âge je veux
créer une nouvelle variable et je vais
l'appeler groupe h
une fois que j'ai défini mais paramètres
ici je vais aller à côté sur découpage
en classe on l'a vu il ya plusieurs
manières de découper en classe on peut
faire des classes de même largeur des
classes de même basées sur les cartes il
là pour ma part ce qui va m'intéresser
c'est plutôt de définir moi même des
limites d'âge d'entrée de jeu pour me
faciliter la vie et parce que je veux
exclure personne je coche inclura
valeurs extrêmes et les valeurs extrêmes
pour être certain qu'on aura bientôt
maintenant ou découpées là on pourra
avoir de longs débats et savoir quels
sont les bons usages ou découpées bas
dépend un peu de votre situation de
votre enquête et les voitures et votre
sujet vous feriez une enquête sur les
adolescents avec une majorité des gens
qui seraient âgés de moins de 30 ans on
ferait peut-être des intervalles petit
vous auriez une très grosse enquête avec
des dizaines de milliers de personnes
éventuellement pourrait prendre des
groupes de dix ans des groupes de cinq
ans d'âge parce qu'on aurait assez de
monde dans chacune de ces classes d'âge
là on a que deux mille personnes pour
garder la précision parce que plus on
coupe en petit modalités mon âne monde à
chaque fois et plus du coup on va être
en manque de puissance pour faire des
tests ou pour faire des comparaisons
je vais essayer des coupes et uniquement
cinq groupes d'âge ce qui m'intéresse
c'est les grands âges de la vie
donc on peut compter 25 ans parce que
souvent on dit bas en dessous de 20 à
partir de 25 ans vous n'avez plus la
carte 12-25 vous avez pu vous êtes plus
considéré comme un jeune au niveau
social donc je l'aï promis 6,25
peut-être que sur d'autres études on
pourrait dire 30 ans serait un meilleur
âge les 25 ans est un bon compromis pour
avoir un âge qui correspond un peu à ce
qu'on admet comme la fin la jeunesse et
l'entrée dans la vie active
il ya le départ en retraite qui marque
une grande partie au ris trouve que
l'âge de départ légal en retraite c'est
62 ans
pas mal de personnes partent en retraite
un petit peu avant donc on va prendre 60
ans c'est vraiment très grossièrement un
âge de départ en retraite
et puis bah pour couper entre les deux
et faire des classes un petit peu je la
jouais de 25 à 60 ans on va regarder
éventuellement qu'est ce qui se passe si
je fais 25 40 ans donc j'ai coupé à 25
40 et 60 en cliquant sur que des
résultats je vais voir ce qui se passe
donc là j'ai un premier groupe qui va de
18 inclus à 25 exclu avec lui pour 125
inclus à 40 exclus et ça fait 26 % 40 60
moins 40 59 40 % l'échantillon et 60 97
je vois que j'ai un peu plus de monde
dans la deuxième ici donc peut-être que
je vais couper non pas à 40 mais à 45
ans pour équilibrer un tout petit peu
mais dieu classe centrale alors il n'y a
pas encore une fois un de règle absolue
ce qui est important c'est que vous
fassiez les choses en fonction de votre
sujet de ce qui fait 100 ans votre
contexte donc là j'obtiens mais quatre
classes qui m'intéresse
un paramètre auquel il faut être
vigilant je vous le rappelle c'est le
paramètre intervalle fermé à droite qui
est cocher ou décocher si je l'avais
cochée
j'aurais fait de 18 à 25 inclus puis 25
exclu à 45 inclus
moi je préfère du coup donc à présent
avoir un découpage d'intervalle fermé à
gauche de 18 à 24 ans c'est à dire
jusqu'à la veille de 25
une fois que j'ai les bons éléments je
clique sur donne et ça va me copier le
code à l'endroit de ma syntaxe
ici vous voyez la syntaxe
pour ma part je préfère modifier
légèrement la syntaxe pour adopter une
approche par pip qui me semble un peu
plus facile à lire donc je vais prendre
le premier paramètre ici le passé devant
et le passé avec un piper puis je fais
un retour à la ligne et on va déplacer
tout une annotation donc c'est hdv 2003
âge et je lui passe à cucq si j'exécute
ceci voyons voir la variable que l'on
obtient freq hdv 2003 deux groupes d'âge
j'obtiens bien mais différents groupes
d'âge ya pas de valeurs manquantes par
contre les noms des catégories sont pas
forcément ce qu'il ya de plus facile à
lire et donc du coup je vais les
renommer on avait vu qu'on pouvait aussi
renommée avec un autre à din hm qui
s'appelle l'hiver ce riz coding g
prendre les vélos coding hdmi 2003 c'est
du coup groupage je ne vais pas en faire
une nouvelle variable ça va être ma même
variable donc je garde le même nom à
cette étape là je clique sur codage et
je vais remplacer 18-25 exclu par un
18-24 25 44 45 59 60 et plus ce qui me
permet d'avoir des étiquettes qui sont
un petit peu plus facile à lire
notamment lorsque vous avez des
catégories liens qui vont jusqu'au bout
il ya toujours le prêt de la difficulté
pour les individus comprendra oui mais
que si jeudi 18 25 et 25 44
on sait pas où 25 est inclus donc soyez
toujours vigilants a trouvé un hommage
qui rendent les choses faciles à lire
pour vos pour vos lecteurs par la suite
donc ça me déplace mon code ici dans la
syntaxe
je vais me permettre encore une fois de
passer à une écriture avec un pie pour
un tout petit peu plus de lisibilité
et puis en fait on voit que ça fait
c'est groupage qu'on passe dans les deux
cas donc en fait je peux même simplifie
encore tout ça en enchaînant les pins
alpes
j'ai donc groupage ch dv2000 3h
j'applique le qte et un record je vais
en profiter aussi pour nommer mais
variable et donc dans la foulée je vais
lui donner une étiquette de variables
comme là je veux le faire que sur une
variable je vais pas passer par cette
variable abel ce que j'aurais dû
appliquer en fait à hdi 2003 et par un
vecteur donner mais je peux utiliser la
syntaxe var label je lui donne le
vecteur donc hdv 2003 dollars ou pages
est lui passé un nom donc c'est des
groupes d'âge maintenant que j'ai ma
variable groupe âge je vais mettre à
jour mon analyse univariée pour
remplacer l'âge par le groupe d'âge
puisque j'utiliserai plus que le groupe
d'âge dans la suite des analyses
et on voit ici le résultat sans valeurs
manquantes et avec du coup des
étiquettes beaucoup plus facile à lire
nous avons ici le sexe alors ça va me
parle et là le sexe on à homme et femme
à ce stade là ça change pas grand chose
ce qu'on verra un petit peu plus tard
parce que j'anticipe la régression
logistique c'est quand on va faire une
régression logistique
on aura aussi besoin pour les variables
explicatives d'une modalité de référence
et je crois que c'était cédric malanda
qui demandait qu'est ce qu'on qualifie
une modalité de référence lorsqu'on fait
une analyse de régression logistique
on le verra on va se retrouver à
comparer toutes les autres modalités à
la référence alors on a plusieurs
options pour choisir les modalités de
référence on peut par exemple prendre la
modalité la plus présente dans
l'échantillon ça permet de comparer tous
les groupes au groupe majoritaire
ce qu'on appelle aussi la ce qu'on
appelle aussi le mode de la variable une
autre possibilité c'est de le faire en
fonction de la manière dont se pose les
questions
par exemple est ce que je veux voir en
quoi les femmes diffèrent des hommes où
je voudrais voir en quoi les hommes
diffère des femmes
c'est complètement symétrique c'est
vraiment là une question de comment
est-ce qu'on va vouloir présenter ses
résultats par la suite le modèle et nos
résultats nos analyses seront vraiment
identiques 1
c'est juste une question présentation
des résultats
est-ce qu'on veut voir si les femmes
diffèrent par rapport aux hommes où
est-ce qu'on veut voir si les hommes
diffère par rapport aux femmes
là ce que je vous propose c'est de
prendre les femmes comme référence et de
voir ensuite en quoi les hommes se
comportent différemment la modalité de
référence joué 10 est toujours la
première donc là ce qu'il nous faut
faire c'est changer l'ordre des
modalités encore une fois on l'a vu la
semaine dernière
il ya un an à dean qui permet de faire
ça tout seul donc le à dean qui
s'appelle cette fois ci liveris ordering
je prend du coup la variable
sexe pour le coup je garde le même nom
je clique sera ordonnée et par glisser
déposer
avec ma souris je vais mettre les femmes
avant les hommes j'obtiens ici le code
qui me permet de faire les choses une
fois vous serez alors la fonction en
l'occurrence qui utilisaient ans à la
fonction fct ouvrait les vannes du
package fort car une fois que vous serez
habitués à cette fonction là peut être
que vous l'écrire et directement vous
même et auquel cas ça peut s'écrire un
petit peu plus vite
c'est à dire que hdv sexe de sa m hdv
2003 saks hype fct bris laverhne élevé
juste m femmes les deux syntaxe sont
équivalentes pourquoi d'une part vous
l'avez vu le pape
donc soit je le fais de fichiers de
données en fichiers de tableaux de
données en tableaux données ou ici de
vecteurs en vecteur c'est juste que
c'est intellectuellement plus facile à
lire comme cote parce que ça veut dire
je pars de ce vecteur là je lui applique
une transformation et le tout est
enregistré ici
ensuite sur le fcb la barre si je dis
simplement à cet éleveur femmes
ça prend la modalité femmes cela mais au
début et puis ici à d'autres modalités
salema la suite dans l'ordre où elle
était initialement là il y en a que deux
donc ça va remettre femmes
au début on n'a pas besoin de répéter
toutes les modalités pour plus
d'informations
comme toujours un maintenant vous savez
que c'est la fonction et ses théories de
laval vous n'hésitez pas à regarder
l'aide de la fonction pour voir tout ce
que vous pouvez faire avec et vous allez
voir qu'il ya des possibilités de choses
un petit peu plus compliqué on peut
déplacer avant après mais vous avez des
éléments de base et vous regardez
ensuite comment vous avez tout ce qui
peut être fait en fonction de vos
besoins
je reviens du coup à mon tableau nous
avons ensuite le niveau d'études
et si vous regardez le niveau d'études
on apprend beaucoup de monde à l'it et
une deux trois quatre cinq six sept huit
modalités avec certaines qui sont peu
représentées à il ya que 39 personnes
qui n'ont jamais fait d'études a gardé
les huit modalités tout du long
ça va compliquer l'analyse parce que
quand on a trop de modalités on a pu à
sainement dans chaque modalité et du
coup on perd en puissance donc à chaque
fois un suivant votre cas de figure la
question se pose de recoder est de
regrouper des modalités ensemble pour
avoir des groupes un peu plus
consistants on perd de la data 2 - la
finesse d'information parce qu'on
regroupe mais on gagne grandement en
puissance et en facilité
d'interprétation d'autre part on a un
petit problème c'est qu'il ya quand même
112 individus qui sont manquants 112 sur
une population totale de 2000 ça
représente un sarre près donc 112 sur
2000 ça représente à peu près 5 ennemis
6%
du coup si je les garde comme manquants
à ils vont être exclue de toutes les
analyses exclure trois quatre personnes
d'une analyse c'est pas forcément
dérangeant exclure un ou deux pourcent
l'analyse pas forcément être dérangeant
mais quand on arrive à 5 6% ça commence
à faire beaucoup et donc du coup on a
intérêt à ce stade de considérer mon
camp comme une modalité en soins donc
c'est à dire qu'ils ne soient plus des
aides à des notes valley bank melli
reconnaît comme une modalité en soi et
vous voir comment elle se comporte dans
l'analyse quitte à ce que plus tard on
se dise finalement ça vous a été là on
peut exclure ces individus ou ou alors
parce qu'on appelle une analyse de
sensibilité
vous faites une analyse ou vous incluez
les manquant une analyse ou vous excluez
les manquants et vous regardez si ça
change le résultat
donc on va recoller le niveau d'études
on l'a vu on a un add in pour ça donc
l'hiver ns oui coding le tableau avait
2003 c'est la variable nive études je
vais créer une nouvelle variable que je
vais appeler étude est ce que je vous
propose c'est de regrouper ceux qui
n'ont jamais fait d'études avec
du niveau primaire donc primaires ça va
correspondre à ceux qui ont atteint le
niveau primaire complet ou incomplets
ceux de premier ou second cycle je vais
les mettre dans le niveau secondaire
je vais recouper techniques
professionnelles là vous avez le court
et le long je vais rhdp en une seule
catégorie et enfin supérieur et puis ici
balle et n a donc les valeurs manquantes
1 je vais les transformer en une valeur
explicitement donc ça va devenir une
nouvelle modalité de ma variable elles
seront ne seront plus manquantes
une fois que j'ai indiquées mais
changement ici je peux cliquer sur que
des résultats sam génère le code
correspondant est ici je peux vérifier
comment l'art code se fait donc j'ai
bien primaire qui récupère les trois
premières modalités secondaire technique
professionnelle puis supérieur et enfin
mon camp je clique sur donne ça
m'affiche le code ici dans mon fichier
de syntaxe
comme vous le savez je préfère une
syntaxe un petit peu différente avec les
papes qui s'enchaînent on veut juste
réécrire sous forme de paille peut faire
un retour à la ligne pour plus de
lisibilité
et puis du coup on peut enchaîner les
deux commandes puisque tout va dans
études donc fct recode me permets de
recoder des modalités existantes dans de
nouvelles modalités si elles ont même
nom savall a coupé ensemble et fct
explicite aide à me permet de
transformer les valeurs manquantes en un
niveau explicite à dire en une valeurs
manquantes
ce qui fait que maintenant mais
pourcentage vont inclus éléments quand
je vais faire mon tableau je crée ma
nouvelle variable
de la même manière je vais donner va la
belle attention
hdv 2003
[Musique]
dollars études et donc ça je vais donner
une valeur qui va être du coup niveau
d'étude aussi jeu alors je vais
remplacer du coup la variole nive étude
par ma nouvelle variable études dans mon
tableau descriptif
j'ai bien une variable niveau d'étude
parfaitement recoder avec ses
différentes modalités on a gardé l'ordre
dont du coup primaire secondaire
technique supérieure manquant donc je
vais l'ordre correspond à ce qu'on
fait sans sens puisque là on a quelque
chose qui qui est avec ingrédients qui
monte
j'ai ensuite la variable rapport à la
religion
pour le moment on va pas modifier les
modalités existantes telles qu'elles
apparaissent
et puis enfin gema variable earth
quotidienne de télévision que je vais
garder en une variable continue donc
avec 2,25 en moyenne et puis j'ai cinq
valeurs manquantes
5 ça fait vraiment pas beaucoup de monde
tant pis on va les perdre pour l'analyse
mais au moins je je je je n'aurai pas à
créer une modalité pour seulement cinq
individus et qui sera du coup qui va
poser problème à la modélisation
comme vous le voyez on a passé pas mal
de temps à préparer nos données à faire
l'analyse univariée alors en soit ce
n'est pas tant l'analyse univariée c'est
la partie retransforme à sion
vérification de chacune des variables
pour les mettre dans un format qui
correspond à ce que l'on a envie de
faire est vraiment à retenir 89 % du
temps c'est la transpiration à préparer
ses data pour 1% consacrer vraiment à la
partie analyse proprement dit
maintenant que nous avons réalisé une
analyse descriptive univariée avant de
se lancer dans une analyse multivariée
et un gros modèles il est toujours
préférable de faire d'abord une analyse
descriptive by variés on s'intéresse ici
à la pratique du sport
on veut voir comment les autres
variables influence la pratique du sport
on va donc commencer par faire une série
de tableaux croisés et de regarder s'il
ya un lien entre les variables
l'analyse by variés se fait très
facilement avec t-bills marie puisqu'on
va reprendre notre code de l'analyse du
tableau univariée simplement je vais
rajouter by égale sport donc en
rajoutant bayaga sport ça va me
représenter un dans mon tableau une
colonne pour chaque valeur du sport
voyons voir le résultat
je vais à grandir le tableau des
résultats donc maintenant pour chacune
de mes variable d'intérêt groupe d'âge
sexe niveau d'étude rapport à la
religion heures quotidiennes devant la
télévision j'ai mes pourcentage pour nom
aimé pourcentage pour wii
si vous regardez les pourcentages sont
des pourcentages en colonnes par défaut
autrement dit ça me dit que parmi les
gens qui ne font pas de sport il y à 4,5
pour cent qui sont des 18 24 ans et
parmi et parmi ceux qui font du sport il
ya 15 4% qui ont 18 à 24 ans plutôt que
de présenter des pourcentages en
colonnes ici je vais être plutôt être
intéressé par regardé les pourcentages
en ligne puisque dans le cas présent je
m'intéresse à savoir comment la pratique
du sport varie en suivant nos
différentes catégories
ce que je voudrais c'est le pourcentage
de jeunes qui font du sport et le
pourcentage de personnes âgées qui font
du sport je vais du coup d'antibes et en
samarie modifier le type du pourcentage
vous avez une option personnes ce qui
peut prendre plusieurs valeurs donc
personne dans l'aide
on va nous l'expliquer
clotide de pourcentage ça peut être
colonnes braille ou en sel donc celle
c'est en pourcentage du total 1 c'est à
dire la cellule et par des fossés les
pourcentages en colonne qui sont
renvoyés on va nous demander nous a
bénéficié des pourcentages en ligne
voyez là on a maintenant les
pourcentages en ligne et on voit tout de
suite
les jeunes sont 66% à faire du sport
contre 19 % des 60 ans et plus et on
voit tout de suite les effets de manière
beaucoup plus efficace pour être pour
être à peu près correct ce serait aussi
pertinent d'avoir une colonne total 1
qui nous qui qui reprend les mêmes
choses et ça on peut le faire facilement
en appliquant résultats tibial se
marient la fonction had au vol alors ça
nous met la crème total avant les
colonnes de modalités pour ma part je me
paraît un peu plus logique d'avoir le
total sur la fin et donc je vais
modifier le paramètre last égale cloud
qui permet de déplacer la colonne total
alors c'est bien d'avoir un tableau mais
moi je vous avouerai je suis quelqu'un
qui est très visuel et donc j'aime bien
avoir un graphique qui me représente les
mêmes données qu'il ya dans mon tableau
pour voir du coup plus concrètement ce
qu'est ce qui se passe
alors on peut faire de très beaux
graphiques à la main où on abordera bas
fin février début mars
on va revenir sur ggp lot 2 1 on avait
vu esquisse qui permettait de faire déjà
des premiers graphique soi même je
pourrais comparer deux variables et mais
on a vu aussi précédemment une fonction
du package et djighaly djédjé galy
fourni plusieurs fonctions pour faire ce
qu'on appelle des graphiques de niveau
supérieur
alors ça va nous préparer rapidement un
graphique
donc je vais déjà chargé gg galli en
mémoire et je vais avoir recours à la
fonction jbe var y est alors le principe
de genivar y est c'est que on part avec
un jeu de données
donc là hdv 2003 puis je vais passer en
fête avec eux avec un prime on va
indiqué jpy var y est la variable
d'intérêt et donc la haute comme et les
variables explicatives donc pour le coup
ici je vais faire comme égal sports et
ex plat n'a tories il lui donnait une
liste de variable donc ici c'est propre
âge sexe
étude religieux et leur tv alors je sais
que ça va peut-être vous perturber que
parfois je mets des listes de variables
sans guillemets comme dans le sélect et
ça c'est parce que sélect à une syntaxe
dit allah dit prêt hier qui nous on va
interpréter les noms de variables en
contexte alors que j'ai gilbert y est
louise qui l'attend c'est une liste
représenté ici à que ces deux noms de
variables dans certains cas on va
indiquer des variables comprises dans le
contexte d'un tableau dans d'autres cas
on doit indiquer une liste représenté
par le sait ici de nom de variables si
vous avez un doute vous regarder à
chaque fois l'aide les fonctions il n'y
a pas besoin de tout retenir par coeur
il suffit de regarder la des fonctions
pour savoir qu'est ce qui a attendu
suivant cas de figure alors qu'est ce
qui se passe si je fais ce graphique là
en fait on obtient rapidement un
graphique qui représente en fait les
mêmes tableaux qu'on avait tout à
l'heure un mais cette fois ci sous forme
de graphique en barres jeu mais cliquer
sur zoom pour les voir en plus grand
donc vous avez les bars avec les
pourcentages l'or perd rapidement sur le
premier graphique en haut vous avez le
groupe d'âge le nom de variable est
indiquée à votre droite les modalités à
gauche
là on voit les 18-24 les 25 44 les 45 59
les 60 et plus en fait on voit du bas
vers le haut et on voit bien qu'il ya un
effet d'âge que plus on est jeune plus
on fait du sport et plus les personnes
devaient nager moins on pratique du
sport
c'est vraiment visible ici avec les
pourcentages de oui on voit que les
hommes font plus de sport que les femmes
concernant le niveau d'études on voit
aussi niveaux primaire secondaire
professionnel supérieur manquant que
plus le niveau d'études est élevé plus
les gens pratiquent un sport
enfin canton
regarde la pratique religieuse c'est pas
très clair ceux qui sont ni croyant ni
qui appartiennent à une religion font un
peu moins de sport que les autres on
voit que ceux qui rejettent revient à 35
voilà il ya un effet qui est pas aussi
marquée qui ait pas aussi clair si je
regarde maintenant sur le nombre
d'heures passées devant la télévision
alors c'est dur à lire parce qu'en fait
ce qui vient jouer beaucoup sur
graphique c'est les personnes qu'il est
le petit nombre de gens qui regardent
beaucoup beaucoup une télévision on voit
que les maximum - 13 par contre si je
regarde les moyennes on avait dans
tableau tout à l'heure et bien sûr les
moyennes ceux qui font pas de sport
regardent en moyenne 2,5 2h30 la
division par jour alors que c'est de 1,8
heures de télé pour ceux qui pratiquent
un sport donc il semblerait qu'ils aient
acquis un effet en turquie un lien entre
les deux gbe var y est je vous présente
ici pour que vous ayez très rapidement
un graphique facile qui vous prennent
rapidement les choses par contre ce
n'est pas le graphique le plus beau là
les variables sont pas remises en forme
et c'est peuvent et il faut voir c'est
cette graphie qu'on mettrait opel dans
une publication ce qui est à retenir
c'est qu'on a souvent de problèmes
soit on a une fonction qui permet
d'avoir rapidement les résultats à
l'étape de l'analyse où on en est et
puis faire un beau graphique ou un beau
tableau est là ça prend beaucoup
beaucoup de temps quand on est en phase
exploratoire fait des graphiques rapide
et efficace de même pour les tableaux
une fois que vous serez les éléments qui
sont finaux et qui vous serviront dans
un papier ou dans un rapport à ce moment
là on pourra passer du temps à essayer
de faire des choses beaucoup plus
esthétique donc à ce stade
restons sous la forme la plus simple si
vous êtes intéressés pour améliorer le
résultat de 10 variétés va regarder en
fait les options de bi variété gbe
variés du cou à différents types
d'options et puis voyez là il ya des
trois points qu apparaisse et trois
points c'est nous dit des as 10 des
options additionnelles qu'on passe à gg
duo parce que en fait ça veut donc dire
que j'ai bien varié prépare des choses
puis à pelvoux qui s'appelle g
et du haut et si je veux voir la 2g du
haut on voit tout un tas d'autres
options supplémentaires très souvent ces
fonctions qui permettent d'aller vite
essaye de vous donner un maximum de
choses pour pouvoir personnaliser au
maximum même si c'est parfois bas un
petit peu plus
parfois c'est un peu plus compliqué
maintenant on a un tableau de nos
résultats on voit par exemple que le
nombre d'heures passées devant la
télévision est un peu plus élevé chez
ceux de la colonne non la question c'est
est-ce que les effets sont significatifs
donc on aurait tout intérêt à regarder
est ce qu'il ya un effet significatif en
bi varié donc à faire des tests de
comparaison pour sa comparaison moyenne
si on affiche des moyennes comparaison
médiane si c'est la médialle qu'on
aurait affiché ou test du kit 2 pour
comparer des variables catégorielles
l'avantagent on l'a vu c'est que on peut
faire ça très vite grâce hajiti se marie
en rajoutant l'option hats pied et donc
en rajoutant adpi ici savard calculé mon
tableau est calculée l'épée valeurs dont
4 pin fonctionne que contiennent
variable bail qui est passé à tibial se
marie on voit qu'on a un effet
significatif de l'âge ici à 1% un effet
significatif du sexe en tout cas en
analyse univariée un effet du niveau
d'études on a une variable rapport à la
religion car en effet on a 14 % dont 14%
on considère qui a pas vraiment d'effet
puisque souvent la limite pour apprendre
et 5% mais on serait à 80 à 0,8 à 0,9
vont dire bay a pas d'effet est là on
est sur quelque chose
voilà qui n'est pas très clair et qui
peut nécessiter d'être explorée et enfin
on a aussi un effet fortement marqué
pour le nombre d'heures quotidiennes
passées devant la télévision
alors la difficulté qu'ils se posent
lors ce que l'on à des données bi variés
sait qu'il peut y avoir des effets qui
se mélangent
je vais prendre un exemple qui est celui
du sexe et du niveau d'études
si je fais un petit graphique dont j'ai
fait hdv 2003 gg vive harriet et je vais
regarder donc le niveau d'études et
l'âge
donc là je vous fais un graphique
rapidement ce qu'on voit c'est que les
60 ans et plus ou moins niveau primaire
pour moitié d'entre eux est en fait ce
qu au niveau primaire c'est surtout les
60 ans et plus soudée 45-59 ans mais sur
la jeune génération qu'à 25 44 ans très
peu s'arrêter au niveau primaire et très
peu s'arrêter au niveau secondaire la
majorité a atteint un niveau technique
professionnelle ou supérieur on voit que
chez nos 18 24 ans quand c'est documenté
alors une grosse partie est plutôt dont
le
dans le technique professionnelle parce
qu'en fait la moitié pour la moitié
d'entre eux
la formation est manquante probablement
parce que cela moitié d'entre eux est
toujours en train de faire des études et
donc du coup n'a pas encore atteint un
niveau d'études et la variet n'aura pas
été documentés quoi qu'il en soit il ya
un effet très marquée entre le groupe
d'âge et entre le niveau d'études
or on voit dans nos donné en bis variés
c'est que la pratique du sport diminue
avec l'âge et augmente avec le niveau
d'études a donc ceux qui font plus de
sport ce sont les jeunes et les éduquer
et ce qu'on voit c'est que les jeunes
sont les plus éduqués autrement dit un
deux effets convergent et donc est ce
qu'il ya un effet de l'âge ou en fait
qu'on voit dans l'âge ça serait un effet
du niveau d'études ou est-ce qu'on a un
effet du niveau d'études ou en fait ce
qu'on voit dans le niveau d'études et un
effet d'âge et comme en fait plus les
gens sont éduqués pluies sont jeunes
c'est pour ça qu'on verrait une plus
grande pratique du sport c'est en raison
de ce type de question qu'on va aller
faire un modèle multivariée le but du
modèle multi variés tels que la
régression logistique
ça va être d'estimer un effet de l'âge à
niveau d'études légales et un effet du
niveau d'étude à groupe d'âge égal on va
donc faire une régression logistique
ordinale pour mesurer sa je vous
présente rapidement comment se fait le
calcul de la régression logistique c'est
ce qui prend le moins de temps en fait
je vais faire j'ai fait je verrai au sto
qui le résultat dans un objet de jeu
appelé mode 1 pour modèle on pourrait
l'appeler règles pour régression la
régression logistique fait partie de ce
qu'on appelle les extensions des modèles
linéaires
pour rappel un modèle linéaire consiste
à essayer de mobiliser la valeur d'une
variable continu en fonction d'autres
variables
or là dans le cas présent ce qu'on a ce
n'est pas une variable continu une vanne
binaire qui vaut oui non
sauf que plusieurs réalisations de cette
variable binaire peut être vu comme une
proportion et on va passer par une
fonction qui s'appelle la fonction le
guide qui va permettre de transformer
des occurrences de wiaih de nom en des
probabilités et en une variable continu
et donc en fait la régression musique
binaire on passe par une fonction de
transformation la fonction le gips pour
repasser dans un contexte dit linéaire
et c'est pour ça qu'on parle de modèles
linéaires généralisée et y en a plein
des modèles linéaires généraliser la
régression logistique binaire les
modèles de poisson quand on est des
variables de type quand tu te dire de
comptage des des modèles négative binôme
you donc là
retenez que tous ces types de modèles
qui sont des extensions du modèle
linéaire en fait se font par des modèles
linéaires généralisé ou generals linea
modèle est donc via la fonction chez
elle la fonction glm
la fonction j'aime on va lui donner
l'équation du modèle puis on va indiquer
le type de modèle alors l'équation du
modèle s'écrit de manière simple c'est
la variable a expliqué ici c'est sport
until death on retrouve un set ce type
qu'on a vu plusieurs fois c'est ce qu'on
appelle des formules dans l'air et qui
historiquement été développé
spécifiquement pour les modèles
d'ailleurs donc la variable expliqué
until depuis la liste des variables
explicatives séparés par ainsi plus en
l'occurrence groupe âge sexe études
religieuses tv on va indiquer avec le
paramètre family le type de modèle donc
family égale binomiale canton en faire
un modèle de régression logistique pour
ceux qui sont intéressés par défaut
binomiale va produire un modèle de type
le guide certains peuvent connaissent
peut-être les modèles de type probit
qu'on peut aussi faire avec binomiale
mais pour les autres si vous savez pas
la différence entre le guide et probit
vous posez pas la question
utiliser le modèle par défaut donc
binomiale pour un modèle dit le guide
enfin il faut qu'on indique le jeu de
données et donc date à égal hdv 2003 et
là on vient de faire une régression
logistique voyez ça nous a pris pas
beaucoup de temps pour la vente achète
les modèles linéaires généraliser ce
calcul très très vite maintenant ce qui
va être un peu plus compliqué c'est de
comprendre comment interpréter nos
résultats la première chose qu'on peut
faire c'est afficher le modèle dans la
console si vous affichez le modèle dans
la console vous allez voir différents
coefficient l'interceptent des
coefficients pour les variables qui sont
catégorielles plus un coefficient pour
heures tv
on peut voir quelque chose d'un peu plus
poussée en faisant ce mallery mode
là on va retrouver nos différents koffi
du modèle leur niveau et enfin à l'épée
va lui associer super forcément ce qu
elle plus lisible et on va voir que pour
avoir un tableau pratique et facile à
lire on va pouvoir passer par la
fonction
cybergun également fourni par jetty se
marier alors affichant les résultats
dont je vais je pars de mon modèle et je
vais appliquer tibial pour voir les
coefficients de nos modèles ça prend
quelques secondes à calculer et vous
avez ici le résultat je vais agrandir le
tableau obtenu parlons alors et par
défaut on nous affiche pas
l'interceptent je vais rajouter
l'interceptent dans ce tableau de
résultats
donc ce que l'on retrouve ici un scellé
coefficient du modèle les mêmes que l'on
avait vu juste ici -0 38 - 0 41 - 06
simplement avec un petit arrondi plus de
mise en forme
vous avez un intervalle de confiance à
95 % et l'épée valeurs associées
l'intervalle de confiance 95 % n'étaient
pas présentés ici dans le sommer et
maintenant il s'agit de comprendre ce
que veut dire les résultats du modèle
l'interceptent ça correspond à la valeur
prédite par le modèle lorsqu'on est à la
référence pour toutes les variables
donc je m'explique si on est si vous
prenez un jeune de 10 de 17 ans d'audit
de 19 ans il n'y a pas de confusion
associés c'est un garçon ya pas de
coefficient associés il est du niveau
d'études primaires la pâte coefficient
associés ils pratiquent la religion
régulièrement c'est la maudite et de
référence et il ne regarde pas la
télévision
donc du coup il n'y a aucun coefficient
qui ce qui le concerne en fait c'est ce
qu'on appelle l'individu à la référence
il est à la référence pour toutes les
modalités
le modèle nous prédit que cet individu a
une certaine probabilité de faire du
sport ce que le modèle nous prédit cse
-0 38
alors -0 38 c'est la prédiction du
modèle à la référence donc pour qu'un
individu qui a la référence partout la
question c'est comment s contre on
traduit ce -0 38 ans une probabilité
je lui dis on était sur un modèle low
git et donc du coup on peut il faut
faire la fonction loggins inversée pour
pour quelques pour que le calculer pour
calculer le coefficient est repassé en
probabilité d'accord je vous montre
rapidement la fonction d'un guide pour
peut-être que vous preniez bien je vais
récupérer la fonction binomiale donc si
je vais faire b binomiale encore
j'obtiens d'objets b et l'intérêt cet
objet blessé il contient plusieurs
choses dont link fun la fonction de lien
et les cas inverse la fonction inverse
je vous montre à cette fonction le guide
d'accord
retenez pas forcément le code que je
mets en bas mais voilà j'ai tracé en
fait la fonction le guide d'accord le
principe de cette fonction de guide
et puis je vais à grandir un tout petit
peu l'échelle le principe c'est que si
vous avez une probité de 50% la fonction
le guide va produire la valeur zéro plus
la probabilité augmente ça à produire
une valeur élevée et en fait c'est un
peu on continue donc tu es plus on se
rapproche de 1 plus les valeurs
deviennent extrêmement élevé et de la
même manière si on allait profiter
qu'ils sont en dessous de 50% les
valeurs vont diminuer
et plus on se rapproche de 0,1 pour me 1
pour 10 milliards un plus on va avoir un
coefficient très bas donc ça c'est la
fonction le git qui utilisait pour
transformer nos données observées avant
de croiser plier le modèle linéaire
le modèle linéaire nous renvoie donc un
coefficient on l'a vu tout à l'heure un
coefficient -0 38 sur l'échelle du login
et la question c'est -0 38 ça correspond
à quel pourcentage vous faire
l'opération inverse
je vous montre à quoi ressemble la
fonction inverse
alors il faut que je fasse
jacques on dit c'est un petit peu donc
je vous montre la fonction inverse
d'accord qui prend des commissions qui
vont de moins d'1 fini à plus l'infini
pour ensuite produire un résultat qui
est située entre 0 et 1% plus le login
et tout en bas
plus on va avoir une probabilité tout
faible plus on va être
on va avoir un chiffre très très grand
plus on est proche de 100 % et 0 ça
correspond à 50%
donc si je regarde maintenant que ce que
représente sur -38 je reviens ici à mon
intercepte si je regarde ce que
représente ce -0 38 ce -0 38
c'est donc la probabilité c'est la
valeur du modèle pour la personne à la
référence et j'applique cet élément là
ça représente 40 %
retenez parra le fait de faire des liens
vers ça je vous fais pour vous expliquer
le mode est là vous verrez qu'on ne dise
pas ça en général pour présenter nos
résultats mais donc retenez ce -0 38 si
j'applique la fonction l'hoggy l'inversé
je re calcule la probabilité de faire de
sport pour quelqu'un qui est à la
référence et cette probité à la
référence est donc de 40% à 41%
c'est donc pour un homme de 18 24 ans de
niveau d'études primaires
pratiquant régulièrement la religion et
ne regardant pas télévision c'est à dire
avec un zéro ici simon mon internet
avait été au dessus d'eux était positif
ça voudrait dire que la probité de
basses est supérieur à 0,5 à 50%
maintenant que se passe-t-il si je
prends un individu qui ne changent de
l'individu de base que par l'âge c'est à
dire j'ai quelqu'un qui a 60 ans et plus
mais ça reste un homme de niveau
d'études primaires qui pratiquent
régulièrement la religion et qui ne
regarde pas la télévision
donc la seule différence que cet
individu aura par rapport à la référence
est d'être un homme
dans ce cas là je vais additionner mais
coefficient donc j'ai -0 38 - 1 3
j'obtiens -1 68
et si ce -68 je regarde je le converti à
l inverse
ça m'amène à une probabilité de faire du
sport de 16 %
donc on voit qu'un coefficient négatif
il vient se rajouter à ce qui se passait
donc pour les individus qu'on 60 ans et
plus on va rajouter ce coefficient de -1
3 5 coefficient négatif ça va donc tirer
les probabilités vers le bas donc on
peut dire que les gens de 60 ans et plus
au moins de chance de faire du sport que
les jaunes 18 à 24 ans pour bien
comprendre le modèle regardons
maintenant le cas de figure d'une femme
de 25 ans une femme de 25 ans qui
regardent la division 2 heures par jour
donc je pars de l'interceptent -0 38
elle a 25 ans et entre 25 44 un
coefficient de -0 42 c'est une femme - 0
44 elle est de niveau d'études supérieur
+ 1 9l et pratiquante régulière de la
religion pas de coefficient zéro et elle
regarde la télévision deux heures par
jour
le pour les variable continu par les
variables catégorie a mais les variables
continue le coefficient doit être
multiplié par la valeur de la variable
donc -0 12 x 2 j'obtiens donc une
nouvelle valeur qui est 0.41 et qui peut
être associé à une probabilité de faire
du sport qui est 2 60%
autrement dit une femme de 25 ans de
niveau d'études supérieur qui pratiquent
régulièrement la religion et qui
regardent la télévision deux heures pas
jours aurait d'après le modèle une
probabilité de 60% de faire du sport
donc le modèle nous donne une équation
qui permettrait pour chaque individu de
recalculer une probabilité de se faire
du sport est telle que le modèle est
construit vous voyez que l'effet de
chaque variable s'applique toujours
indépendamment des autres variables et
donc les coefficients du modèle nous
permet de regarder les faits d'une
variable toutes choses égales par
ailleurs qu'il faut entendre comme tout
autre chose dans le modèle égales par
ailleurs
alors souvent sur un modèle dont sur un
modèle quels qu'ils soient un modèle
linéaire modèle le poisson modèles de
régression logistique modèle de cox pour
l'année de survie les coefficients se
compare à 0 0 pas d'effet coefficient
positif un effet positif on augmente le
résultat l'un l'occurrence la probité de
faire du sport et un chiffre négatif
loin de zéro on diminue les faits donc
le sens de la valeur du coefficient nous
indique les effets vous voyez là les
coefficients les additionner les uns aux
autres on est dans une logique qui est
additive on veut savoir du coup si notre
coefficient est différente 06 un
coefficient est différent de zéro
autrement dit il ya un effet
significatif s'il n'est pas différente 0
n'a pas d'effet
donc là vous voyez que le moins 0,44
j'ai une paire valeur de mou 0,001 ça me
dit que j'ai en effet significativement
différente que mon coefficient est
significativement différente 0 donc les
femmes sont significativement différente
des hommes en matière de pratique du
sport et on peut même dire du coup que
la probité de faire du sport pour une
femme est significativement différente
que la probité de faire du sport pour un
homme de la même manière
vous voyez vous voyez ici des effets et
en fait on combat pour niveau d'études
d'accord j'ai cinq modalités et en fait
mon coefficient compare systématiquement
une modalité ici secondaire à la
modalité de référence donc là la
probabilité de faire du sport est plus
élevé dans le secondaire par rapport aux
primaires puis on voit que c'est de 1,1
pour le technique par rapport aux
primaires on voit que c'est de 1,9 au
supérieur par rapport aux primaires et
on voit que ces deux les manquants par
rapport aux primaires comme le
coefficient ici des de 1,9 pour
supérieur et qu'il est de 1 pour
secondaire la différence entre supérieur
et secondaire c'est 1,9
- un don qu'elle est de 0,9 dont je peux
dire que les personnes devenues
supérieures font plus de sport que ceux
du niveau secondaire
par contre là j'ai pas de tests de
comparaison directe faudrait que je
refasse le modèle en changeant la
maudite et de référence pour faire le
test proprement dit ce qui est à retenir
c'est que le choix de les modalités de
référence un impact puisque dans les
variables catégorielles d'accord on
compare chaque terme avec la référence
si j'avais pris technique
professionnelle comme monnaie de
référence
j'aurais pas eu les mêmes résultats
j'aurais eu moins 1,1 pour primaire - 1
pour secondaire 0 pour techniques
professionnelles 08 +0 8 pour supérieur
et un virus hin1 pour mon camp là les
éléments on se présenter à cet endroit
là et c'est là où là une question est
posée
est-il problématique d'avoir des petits
effectifs pour la modalité de référence
c'est là où c'est oui ça peut être pré
matic si vous avez des tout petits
effectifs dans une modalité vous avez
une mobilité qui va être très instable
et ça peut du coup rendre votre modèle
instable donc c'est pour ça qu'il est
préférable d'avoir plutôt de référence
où il ya du monde ça veut pas dire c'est
forcément celle où il ya le plus de
monde mais quelque chose
d'avoir une modalité on a de la
précision ceci étant dit on a quelques
éléments pour aborder plus facilement
les effets du modèle indépendamment de
la référence alors je vous passe sur les
contrastes je ferai un jour une session
dédiée à ça mais on est sur des âges
avancés mais ce qu'on va voir c'est
comment voir les effets du modèle
donc je vais vous on va aborder la
notion des faits marginaux pour ça on va
surtout avoir besoin d'une librairie
dont j'ai rajouté au début de mon de mon
script un appel à l'art les bories
effect et je vais vous présenter le
graphique ça se fait très facilement
c'est un graphique je vous recommande
systématiquement de faire quand vous
faites un modèle pour vous c'est pas
forcément graphique on peut facilement
publié par contre c'est un graphique que
je réutilise souvent quand je fais des
présentations à des noms satis titien ou
à des politiques par exemple sur des
résultats
alors je vous montre comment on fait le
graphique des effets marginaux et après
je vous explique comment les interpréter
pour faire les effets marginaux on prend
mode notre modèle on appelle la fonction
hall effect ah oui j'ai pas exécuter mon
library effect donc on applique la
fonction hall effect sur le modèle qui a
calcul tous les effets et ensuite on
applique la fonction pelote pour en
faire un graphique donc ça une manière
équivalente à décrire ses pelotes de all
effect de mode
voyez le fait de passer par le pape
c'est juste pour les mettre dans un
ordre logique
voici le résultat vous faire le
graphique des effets marginaux du modèle
c'est une commande très simple voyons
voir comment est-ce qu'on peut
interpréter ce si l'idée vous l'avez vu
c'est que je peux disait mon modèle pour
prédire la probabilité de faire du sport
pour différentes situations
je pourrai ainsi prédire la mode elle la
probité de faire du sport pour un homme
mais la question je fais ça pour un
homme de 18 24 ans où je calcule cette
probabilité pour un homme de 45 59 ans
ou pour la probabilité de le faire pour
un homme de 60 ans et plus ce que fait
le package effect il dit bah je vais à
calculer pour les jeunes pour les moins
jeunes et pour les ag et pigeons faire
une moyenne d'accord donc ce que fait le
package il utilise le modèle pour
essayer de calcul les prédictions du
modèle pour les hommes entrent à la
moyenne des groupes d'âge la moyenne des
niveaux d'études la moyenne de la
religion la moyenne deux heures tv
d'accord donc en fait c'est comme si je
faisais des prédictions pour tout un tas
de personnes et j'en fais une moyenne
l'intérêt c'est que ça me dit l'effet
est marginal
demain variable sexe et ça me dit
les hommes ont une probabilité de 38% de
faire du sport et les femmes 2 28%
toutes choses égales par ailleurs
c'est-à-dire à un moyenne de l'âge à la
moyenne de l'effet d'études à moyenne
deux heures tv à la moyenne de la région
et vous avez en plus un intervalle de
confiance
alors si vous voulez le chiffre exact il
suffit de faire on les fait kz2 mode je
manque pas en faire un graphique 1 et
vous aurez du coup les choses qui
s'affichent les pourcentages exacts qui
vont s'afficher dans la console de la
même manière
d'accord on voit notre effet d'âge plus
on avance en âge et moi on fait de sport
donc en fait les jeunes font beaucoup de
sport à niveau d'études légales
c'est ça qui est intéressant c'est que
pour un niveau d'études moyen est de la
même manière donc on voit bien qu'il ya
un effet de l'âge indépendamment du
niveau d'études
et qui a un effet du niveau d'études
indépendamment de l'effet d'âge donc en
fait âges et niveaux d'études sont deux
effets qui se qui se conjugue les uns
l'un l'autre
on voit qu'ils aient un effet ici de la
religion bac est pas très clair envoyé
ça bouge pas des masses et les
intervalles de confiance sont très
élevés et puis on voit un effet deux
heures télévision alors un coefficient
associer leur tv est pas toujours simple
interpréter là on voit beaucoup mieux ce
qui se passe plus on regarde la
télévision
quand on a la moyenne tu restes quand on
regarde pas la télévision par jour ben
on est autour de 38 % de chances de
faire du sport alors que ceux qui
regardent 10 heures pas jour n'ont
qu'une probabilité de 18% de faire du
sport donc l'intérêt des effets
marginaux c'est que vous voyez les
effets sont représentés en probabilité
ici j'aurais fait un modèle linéaire en
fait c'est les effets vous sont
présentées dans la grandeur de votre
variable analyser et ça permet de
visualiser nos effet si j'avais changé
mais modalités de référence dans mes
variable ça aurait modifié mais
coefficient mais les effets marginaux
serait resté inchangé donc ça permet de
voir comment les choses les effets qu'on
observe dans le modèle indépendamment du
choix des coefficients et en plus au
lieu d'avoir des coefficients qu'il faut
arriver à 30 soit dans sa tête c'est
positif négatif
là on vous parle directement en
pourcentage c'est à dire en probabilité
de faire du sport alors on peut faire
des graphiques un petit peu plus joli il
faut savoir que
pour faire il vous présente en même
temps j'ai fait qd donc gg effect est
une librairie un package qui utilisent
effect mais qui représente des
graphiques un petit peu mieux
donc si je vous montre maintenant ce qui
se passe avec gégé effect alors je vais
vous faire déjà pour une variable
données donc si je fais gg effect modèle
juge pour le sexe ça vous présente les
faits pour la variable sexe il ya sous
un petit tableau qui est plus facile à
lire comme mon résultat de tout à
l'heure là et puis je peux faire là
dessus
pelote et là vous avez le graphique un
petit peu plus propre et un petit peu
plus présente et vous voyez aussi que
gégé effect reprend nos étiquettes de
variables sexe dont pour naomi
présentation du graphique qui est un
petit peu mieux fait
petite précision si je supprime ici
j'indique pas un terme précis vous
obtiendrez en fait un graphique pour
chacune des variables
sauf que c'est pas toujours pratique
d'avoir un graphique pour toutes les
variables ont préféré avoir plus tôt un
graphique donc ça ça va nous fait une
liste de graphiques
ce qu'on voudrait savoir plus tôt tout
ça sur un seul graphique
alors pour ceux que ça intéresse on y
reviendra mais vous avez plusieurs
paquets j'ai plusieurs manières qui
permettent de combiner plusieurs
graphiques ensemble vous avez un
chapitre dédié qui aborde comment est ce
qu'on peut
fusionner une liste de graphiques pour
faire des ronds plusieurs graphiques on
va les mettre ensemble
vous n'avez pas de grille de cahors lot
le package patchwork ou la fonction
multi pelote ce qu'on retrouve beaucoup
sur internet
l'âge augmente rapidement ce comment on
va faire ça avec claude wild il n'y a
pas besoin de tout retenir pour nos vous
aurez le corriger de toute façon donc en
fait
retenez juste à bas pour les effets je
vais sur chapitre analyseur parce que je
que je vous montre là quand même pour
rappeler ses dents chapitre régression
logistique et si vous allez dans
régression justice binaire
représentation graphique des effets ce
qu'on est en train de voir je vous le
présente donc vous avez le code
donc en fait ce que je vous dis là ce
qui est important ce n'est pas de
retenir par coeur la syntaxe c'est de
savoir que ça existe savoir ah oui tiens
je peux faire ce graphique là c'est sûr
analyseur chapitre régression logistique
et retrouver le code donc pour fusionner
une liste il ya la fonction copilote
pelote grid et plock bride c'est ce
qu'on lui passe une sérigraphie qu'un
parent soit on y passe une liste
graphics qui est le retour qu'on a donc
ses pelotes liste et alors il se trouve
que plati ce n'est pas le premier
paramètre de pelote grid
donc quand on utilise le pape et qu'on
veut en fait passer ce qui avant à un
endroit précis
il suffit d'utiliser un point encore une
fois c'est des éléments de syntaxe qui
viendront fur et à mesure mais si je
fais ça vous avez un graphique avec tous
les ils sont tous mis ensemble et là on
peut comparer petite précision et soyez
vigilants ici ça c'est un graphique est
vraiment à mon avis a utilisé en interne
pas en communication externe notamment
parce que les échelles ne sont pas les
mêmes
vous voyez là on a 20 à 60% alors qu'on
en est de 25 à 40%
si je devais communiqué ces résultats à
une
un public de non spécialistes par
exemple si vous présentez une ong ou à
des politiques
ce type de graphique à moi je les
reprendrai notamment pour que toutes les
échelles sur les mêmes puisque là il
faut être vigilant que ce point là je
peux pas le comparer avec ce point là
parce qu'en fait je devrais être en
dessous voilà c'est déjà de petits
détails qu'il est important de bien
avoir en tête mais à moins que la
fonction pelote de gégé effect permettre
d'eux ce qu'ils proposent
non
waouh
alors il ya une question de sandrine
alors il ya d'autres questions j'ai vu
un jeu auquel je reviendrai en fin de
session mais question de sandrine à je
ne comprends pas trop le sens que cela
donne la proba pour les modalités la
variable x les variables étant la
moyenne pour des vars cali à cette
notion de moyenne pour des variables
qualitative
je pense que c'est ça qui doit vous
perturber revenons au graphique en
question with whom alors supposons qu'on
comprend un modèle un peu plus simple il
y aurait que le sexe et le groupe d'âge
d'accord effectivement la moyenne du
groupe d'âge fait pas sens et l'idée
c'est que je pourrai calculer une
probabilité pour les 18-24 une
probabilité pour 25 44 une probabilité
pour 45 59 et une probabilité pour 60
ans et plus g4 probabilité pour groupes
d'âge peut faire la moyenne des quatre
si je m'intéresse par exemple aux
quelques ensuite s'il y avait le niveau
d'étude je peux calculer une probabilité
pour primaire une pour secondaire une
pour professionnels une cour supérieure
une pour manquant g5 valeur pour niveau
d'étude je peux en faire une moyenne
en fait c'est la moyenne en considérant
que chaque catégorie est équitablement
représentées dans l'échantillon vu que
j'ai deux variables en fait ce qui a
fait le modèle il ya calculer toutes les
combinaisons de âge avec toutes les
combinaisons de sport pour calculer une
moyenne alors techniquement c'est même
un peu plus simple je vais revenir sur
notre tableau
en fait il suffit de considérer la
moyenne en fait pour ce calcul a c'est
qu'on fait 0 - 0 42 - 1 - 3 on en fait
la moyenne qu'on applique aux -0 38 en
fait on peut se trouver une situation
moyenne
il suffit de dire que je vais considérer
la moyenne des coefficients pour groupe
d'âge le nom moyens quand on pense aux
graphiques un faux pas le voir au sens
statistique du terme
les hôpitaux sont au sens conceptuel
pardon donc le graphique ce qu'il faut
comprendre c'est on cherche à savoir les
fêtes
comparez les hommes et les femmes il
faut les comparer une situation et on
prend une situation moyenne
c'est juste ça qui est qu'à retenir mais
du coup ce que l'on voit son graphique
c'est pas les pourcentages de m pour
sage de femmes qui font réellement du
sport ça on l'a dans nos données ça nous
donne toutes choses égales par ailleurs
l'effet pure du sexe une fois qu'on a
retiré l'effet du niveau d'études
l'effet de l'âge l'effet de la religion
et les fait du nombre d'heures passées
devant la télévision
donc en fait une sorte d'effet contrôlé
par les autres variables du modèle et
c'est d'ailleurs pour ça qu'on fait un
modèle logistique
reste quand même avant de continuer un
élément important à avoir
je vous ai montré à notre graphique des
thermes
mais dans le cas d'une régression
logistique très souvent vous ne verrez
pas les coefficients directement ou
verrier plutôt ce qu'on appelle
l'élaboration alors les autres ratio
c'est ce qu'on appelle un rapport de
corte
donc pour rappel sur ce que c'est qu'une
quote si vous jouer aux courses vous
avez un cheval on dit qu'il ya une cote
de 3 contre 1 c'est parce que 75% des
gens paris qui va gagner et donc in donc
une probité de 0,64 et si je divise 0,75
par 1 - 0 75 inverse c'est à dire qu'il
a une cote de 3 en train une cote de 3
supposons par contre qu'il ya un autre
cheval et que la plupart des gens sont
persuadés il ya que 10 % des gens qui
pensent qu'il va gagner que 90% des gens
pensent qu'il va perdre lui va avoir une
mauvaise cote
il ya 10% des gens qui pensent qu'il va
gagner et donc un moins 10 points 0,10
ça veut dire dans 90 % de gens qui va
perdre il ya donc une cote de 0,11
techniquement ça s'appelle une cote de 9
contre 1 aussi 1 / 9 maintenant donc la
cote du cheval à ces trois-là codes du
cheval b c 01
lequel des deux est le meilleur coach
pour calculer s'il ya une côte meilleur
que l'autre je peux faire un rapport des
codes j'ai divisé les de kot une part
l'autre donc la cote de à part à bord a
b c donc 0 75 / 0 point et on obtient du
coup c'est dieu n'en parlons c'est 3 /
on obtient un autre ratio de 27 alors là
j'ai pris des codes qui sont très très
différentes mais du coup l'aude ratio
c'est le rapport des colts maintenant
prenons le cas de figure
je reviens à mon modèle d'accord donc on
a vu si je prends un individu qui est à
la référence il a une probité de faire
du sport qui va être link inverse qui 2
-2 46% ça c'est la probabilité de faire
du sport pour pour quelqu'un qui a la
référence si je prends maintenant
quelqu'un la référence excepté sur l'âge
et qui est à qui à 26 ans donc là je
vais faire -0 38 - 0 42 j'obtiens du
coup 31 % d'accord donc ça c'est la
probabilité 1 pour quelqu'un qui à 26
ans par rapport à quelqu'un qui à 19 ans
quel est l'autre l'opération entre les
deux donc c'est on peut calculer
directement avec la fonction aux ratios
donc le premier je veux le hot ratio du
de 25 44 ans dont 31 pour cent par
rapport à 0 42 61 2 6 9
j'obtiens à notre ratio de 0 6 157
donc si les probabilités avait été égale
là quand on passe à un autre à sion on
est sur un on est pure logique a dit
yvon néologique multiplicatif donc là un
deux choses sont égales l'une /
l'automne 1
et puis des valeurs au dessus de 1 nous
donne
voilà bah du coup ça augmente et sinon
des valeurs inférieures à 1 entre 0 1
nous disent que du coup ça réduit la
probabilité dont claude ratio entre la
probabilité faire du sport poursuite 25
44 ans par rapport à ceux de 18 24 c
zéro 657 je me suis un peu embêté a
calculé qu il se trouve que si je prend
0,42 et que jean calcul exponentielle
dont je fais l'exponentielle 2
- 0 42 j'obtiens aussi 0 65 70 468 donc
ça c'est une particularité des modèles
de régression logistique qui est que
l'exponentielle des coefficients
correspondent à des zones ratio et c'est
pour ça que souvent plutôt que de
présenter les coefficients on présente
les zones ratio est donc avec tibial
riche si on veut présenter les zones
ratio plutôt que les coefficients il
suffit d'indiquer exponentielle
[Musique]
donc là si vous faites exponentielle et
great flu vous avez dirais qu'en fait
vous avez l'exponentielle un des
coefficients donc cette fois ci en garde
plus si un coefficient est négatif ou
positif on regarde si les coefficients
sont inférieurs ou supérieurs à 1 donc
plus les commissions son petit ça veut
dire plus l'effet négatif et al'inverse
plus les effets plus des commissions
sont élevés plus les effets sont
positifs et donc le test ici tu es
simplement si jamais le coefficient est
différent de ce que vous vous rendez
peut-être pas compte c'est que tu y fais
beaucoup de boulot en arrière-plan
pauvres pour faciliter en fait la
présentation notamment envoyé
automatiquement et vous avez mis au vert
parce qu'ils détectent c'est une
régression logistique et qu'on est avec
exponentielle de la même manière vous
avez ici
léa qui détecte en fait ce qu'il y a pas
de commission pour des vingt-quatre
mille détecte du cou qui est des
modalités de référence pour les rajouter
dans le tableau et vous avez du coup un
tableau qui est beaucoup plus facile à
lire
dernier petit élément si vous voulez
afficher du coup une valeur pour les
modalités de référence parce que là en
l'occurrence on peut indiquer 0 ou 1
tout simplement à ce moment là vous
pouvez faire had estimate ku
il ya sourire j'espère c'est bien ça
voilà les donc si on ajoute cette option
là qui est pas obligatoire c'est pour le
coup sûr votre mot sur ce type de modèle
là ce sera plus en plus extrémistes
éthique mais ça rajoutera du coup c'est
valeur de 1 pour les modalités de
référence enfin on a souvent envie aussi
on peut représenter ça facilite les gros
tableau d'avoir plutôt une vision
graphique et là je vous invite à passer
par la gg galy qu'on a déjà utilisé
plusieurs ports gbe variété et gégé galy
propose également une fonction
gg modèle pardon gg coeff modèle voulu
passer un modèle et vous obtenez un
graphique des coefficients je vous
montre le graphique en grand donc zéro
est très bien indiqué par unis verticale
les modalités sont présentés par rapport
aux variables les monnaies de référence
sont rajoutés son graphique avec un
point du coup sûr ce zéro chaque point
indique la valeur du coefficient les
traits noirs indique la valeur de
l'intervalle de confiance donc tout ça
c'est ce qu'on appelle un fort est plate
et puis petite subtilité pour vous aider
à repérer très rapidement si les
coefficients sont significativement
différent d'eux et de l'épée valeurs
sont inférieures à 5 % ou non est bien
entré en pointant les points plein
représentent les coefficients qui sont
significatifs à 5% et ceux qui sont
creux avec un petit point blanc milieu
représente les coefficients qui ont un
effet qui sont signes qui ne sont pas
significatifs à 5%
par ailleurs vous avez l'épée va lieu
qui vous sont rajoutés directement son
graphique mais vous avez énormément
d'éléments qui peuvent être
personnalisés
si vous préférez intervalle de confiance
à 90%
une autre manière d'identifier les
variables significative donc vous avez
d'une part tout un beaucoup d'exemples
dans le fichier de dead et vous avez
aussi une vignette
comme souvent pour beaucoup des
fonctions je vous présente on a un rendu
de base très simple et puis vous avez
beaucoup de personnalisation possible
de même on peut représenter plus tôt les
hawks ratio donc là on va faire un
exponentielle et garou
vous avez le graphique et si vous
regardez bien votre graphique est
quasiment identique et que c'est juste
qu'on a des zones ratio qui sont
présentés mais comme les opérations sont
sur une logique multiplient cathy veine
logique a dit yves il faut utiliser en
fait une échelle logarithmique donc vous
avez 0 3 et 3 ici ce qui en fait revient
à faire exactement le même graphique
c'est vraiment identiques
dernière petite astuce que je vous
montre ce soir depuis le début j'ai
passé j'ai vous avez vu comment j'ai
complété mon script au fur et à mesure
et en fait mon script comporte tous les
éléments qui lui permettent de réaliser
l'analyse
donc si j'ai cliquer sur source il va
être en capacité de tout exécuté depuis
le début son erreur et ça peut le
vérifier
là le script est en train de s'exécuter
de bout en bout mais ce serait quand
même très pratique si je pouvais
produire un document qui contiennent mon
code et les différents résultats les
tableaux les graphiques et les
différents des éléments qui se sont
affichés dans la console alors pour soi
il fallait passer par des rapports
automatisés de type erp markdown on
abordera encore deux fois plus tard mais
depuis la toute dernière version de leur
studio qui est la version
qui est la version 1.4 qui est
disponible qui enfin disponible
officiellement en version stable depuis
une dizaine de jours dont je vous invite
à télécharger la toute dernière version
de leur studio sur un script vous avez
ce petit bouton à côté de la petite
baguette magique qui a une sur de petits
carnets et ça s'appelle c'est l'option
qui s'appelle comparé louis porte si mon
script inclut bien tout les appels au
package dont j'ai besoin l'importer
donné qu'il est autonome d'accord si je
clique ici il je dis je veux un rapport
au format html je clique sur compass il
faut patienter un petit peu hein parce
que forcément il faut qu'il arrive à
tout exécuté mais ça va produire un
document avec l'ensemble de mon code
l'ensemble des tableaux et l'ensemble
des graphiques et ce document du coup ça
sera un fichier html
il va venir is a sapé comme mon script
s'appelle analyse pratique sports.fr ça
va devenir analyse pratique pour under
score sport point je t aime l on va
encore laisser calculer on y arrive et
donc vous
tenez ce document qui contient
d'ailleurs la date du jour et qui
contient tout le code donc code
résultats code résultats au fur et à
mesure et voyez j'ai un tableau qui est
au format html je peux tout simplement
copier coller donc en fait ça me permet
d'avoir très rapidement un rapport avec
tous mes résultats
vous avez aussi l'option de produire non
pas un rapport html mais un rapport
world
ça fonctionne de la même manière et vous
aurez un document word cette fonction
c'est fait pour faire du pas ce que
j'appelle le quick and dirty c'est à
dire que vous avez rapidement votre
résultat mais on a pas on n'a pas un
document un document de travail pour soi
c'est pas un document il ya des bouts de
code on a des éléments voilà c'est
vraiment pour soi qu père et son analyse
et après on va pouvoir copier coller les
éléments dont on a besoin lorsqu'on va
rédiger au propre
un rapport d' enquête un article
scientifique ou une présentation
powerpoint
vous avez aussi une troisième option
dont vous avez html une deuxième option
qui vais donc world une troisième option
qui est pdf on peut faire des pdf
mais attention ça nécessite d'avoir une
installation de la tec sur votre bureau
sur votre pc
donc la tête qu'un c'est un langage de
programmation qui permet de générer des
documents un pdf c'est parfois un peu
compliqué et donc soit vous savez gérer
leur installation si vous avez du tout
fait une sortie world ou une sortie html
ici vous avez sorti world et voyez on
récupère l'ensemble des éléments
notamment les tableaux qui sont des
tableaux world qu'on peut facilement
copier coller et adapté et vous avez
également les images qui sont produites
on verra son chapitre sur
sur ggp lot que là les images ont pas
forcément dans la meilleure résolution
et on passerait par une fonction com ggc
pour fixer une qualité ou alors on
ferait son propre rapport automatisés
mais là en tout cas on a les éléments
requis pour pouvoir démarrer et avoir
très rapidement nous retour
alors on a eu une session un petit peu
plus long que d'habitude cette semaine
et on est encore loin d'avoir fait le
tour de la régression logistique
donc on a une deuxième session concret
consacré à la régression logistique
puisque on va voir a déjà comment
répondre à la question est ce qu'une
variable a globalement un effet ou pas
un effet est-ce que je peux améliorer le
modèle est ce que je dois mettre tous
mes variable dans le même modèle ou est
ce qu'il faut je sélectionne les
variables à partir de l'analyse by
variés avant de les mettre dans mon
modèle est ce que j'ai des techniques
qui permettent de faciliter est-ce qu'il
faut tenir compte de termes
d'interaction qu'est ce que la multi
collinaires et et dont on nous dit
toujours qu'il faut être vigilant
donc ces éléments là on les abordera
dans sept prochaines séances on va
repartir de ce qu'on a fait aujourd'hui
on va repartir de ce modèle là et on va
voir comment on peut améliorer
donc si je regarde vos dernières
questions du chat est ce qu'on retient
que les variables qui sont
significatives en bi variés ou est-ce
qu'il faut toutes les prendre et bah on
rediscutera de ça justement la semaine
prochaine à plusieurs stratégies qui
sont possibles une question dans
l'analyse vivarié peut donc faire le
test de corrélation de personnes entre
la variable dépendante et les variables
explicatives
non le test de corrélation de la
collation de personnes ce calcul entre
deux variables continue donc par exemple
on pourra voir le l'âge et le nombre
d'heures passées devant la télévision
pour deux variables continue on peut
calculer un copain un coefficient de
corrélation de personnes et on peut
faire un test du coup de personnes c'est
pas possible de faire ça quand on a des
variables catégorielles entre deux
variables catégorielles on va faire un
test du chi 2 où est votre montée c'est
exact de fisher entre
deux variables entre les deux variables
catégorielles et une variable continu là
on va avoir des tests de comparaison de
moyenne ou des tests de comparaison de
médiane alors je veux pas je veux pas
remplacer à vos professeurs de
statistiques
vous avez dû les uns les autres à voir
vraiment des cours de statistiques donc
retourné voir beaucoup de statistiques
pour savoir le bon type de test vous
pouvez aussi aller voir des petits
ouvrages qui sont pas très chers pour la
l2 qui sont statistiques descriptives et
statistiques inférentielle sud en poche
qui vous permettent de revoir les bases
de la statistique puisque effectivement
le site analysé n'est pas un site de
statistiques
c'est un site qui vous dit comment
réaliser vos statistiques avec air stud
avec rr studio mais ça vous donne pas
tous les éléments de statistiques donc
éventuellement n'hésitez pas à retourner
voir des cours de statistiques de base
vous avez aussi d'autres qui sont
disponibles en ligne à
et après vous pourrez voir du coup quels
sont les bons les bons tests à utiliser
je regarde s'il reste quelques dernière
question une question de philippe
goursat sur les interactions travail
entre variable du coup on discutera
justement la semaine prochaine la
question sur quelles qu'elles variaient
l'intégrer encore une fois ça sera pour
la semaine prochaine et donc du coup je
vous propose qu'on s'arrête là
pour ce soir à et on se retrouve la
semaine prochaine pour une tout nouveau
bas pour la suite d'aujourd'hui voilà
merci à vous très bonne soirée et à
bientôt
au revoir